-Our next guest
has his comedy special
"Money Never Wakes"
available on YouTube.
Please welcome the very funny
Nathan Macintosh.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey. Hey.
Hey, everybody.
Hi. It's so great to be here.
Right now I'm trying
to figure my life out.
Every single person I know
is starting a family.
I'm losing a lot of friends
to babies.
I should actually say
I'm losing city friends.
I'm getting
my small-town friends back
because their kids are now 18.
[ Laughter ]
People in small towns
just start families younger.
Right? And of course they do.
They're bored.
There's nothing to do
in a small town.
I feel people in a small town
just wake up one day
and look at each other like,
"Look, I don't know.
You want to go see
the trees again?"
[ Laughter ]
"We've already seen the trees.
We counted them.
We measured them.
Well, we could make new people
and show them the trees."
[ Laughter ]
One huge advantage, though,
if you have a baby
in a small town,
you have space,
you have a house and a yard.
I have friends in this city
that are having a baby
in a studio apartment,
an apartment
so small that if they
get too many groceries,
they have to
throw a chair out.
[ Laughter ]
The only good thing about
a city apartment
is your baby
can't just wander off.
You're not going to lose them.
Like, "Where's Chris?"
"What do you mean where's Chris?
He's in the West Wing.
What do you mean where's Chris?
Our oven and shower touch."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I don't know that a lot
of people are taking it.
So everybody wants you
to hold their baby, right?
Every single person wants you
to hold their baby.
Why? It's the most
precious thing you have.
Why are you putting it
in my hands?
People will step over a glass
coffee table covered in candles
to hand you the most
breakable thing they have.
[ Laughter ]
Nobody wants you
to touch their phone.
Not one person.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And I honestly don't --
It bothers me.
I don't think a lot of people
are taking it seriously
because everybody says they're
having a baby, right?
Everybody says baby as if that's
all it's ever going to be.
Babies grow up.
I really wish people said
they were having a future adult
because one day it's a baby
and the next day
it's a guy named Doug.
[ Laughter ]
And Doug is a grown man
standing in your kitchen,
drinking your juice,
and he wants money.
[ Laughter and applause ]
There's a lot of people
that aren't ready
to have a baby, right?
So they get a dog
as a training baby
and they call it a fur baby.
And honest to God,
if you call your dog a fur baby,
do not have a skin baby
because...
[ Laughter ]
You're not taking this
seriously at all.
And having a dog
might be harder sometimes.
I have a tiny little Chihuahua
and it's horrifying.
I don't know if anybody's
ever walked a Chihuahua.
It's scary.
Walking a Chihuahua is like
walking a carton of eggs.
[ Laughter ]
Any single thing can go wrong.
I got to be on the lookout
for other dogs,
people, blowing leaves,
everything.
[ Laughter ]
I don't think people
pushing strollers are worried
that a hawk is going
to come out of the sky.
[ Laughter ]
And take their baby.
But I have vivid thoughts about
chopping a bird out of the air.
[ Laughter ]
Like, "Not today, hawk!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
I just bought her that sweater,
which I never thought
I'd ever be doing.
I never thought I'd be buying
a coat for a tiny little dog.
I never thought
I'd be in a store
like, "She'd never wear green,"
just pushing sweaters
out of the way.
[ Laughter ]
But you have to get clothes
for a Chihuahua
because if you take a Chihuahua
out in the cold without a coat,
they freeze.
They stop living right there.
[ Laughter ]
And then you're a maniac
just dragging a frozen dog
down the street. People are
like, "What happened?"
What happened?
She's supposed to be in Mexico!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Also, when you get a dog,
there's so many places
you can't live any more, right?
Because so many apartments
say no pets,
and you want to get mad
at the landlord,
like they're just making up
these crazy rules.
But people ruined the pets rule
because most people,
when they hear pets,
are like, "Oh, yeah,
a pet, like a cat or a dog."
But some people hear "pets"
and they go, "Oh!
Python."
[ Laughter ]
And then one day there's
a 40-foot snake
roaming the halls,
trying to eat your neighbors
because somebody
doesn't know what a pet is.
A pet is something
that you can pet.
[ Laughter and applause ]
You put your hand on its head
and you pet it.
It's not a creature you fight
with a stick back into a cage.
[ Laughter ]
It's not something you kick
off a riverboat.
[ Laughter ]
It's not something a wizard
puts on a staff.
It's --
It's a cute animal with fur.
Not something Samuel L. Jackson
fought on a plane.
[ Laughter ]
There's so many apartments
that say no pets.
There's not one apartment
that says no babies.
Not one. And why? My dog is five
pounds for life.
You don't know what
this baby's going to be.
[ Laughter ]
This baby could grow
into a 6'5" smoker
that steals packages.
You don't know.
[ Laughter ]
My dog is doing nothing.
She's sitting there shivering,
looking out the window for
hawks.
[ Laughter and applause ]
My name's Nathan Macintosh,
guys.
Thanks so much.
Really appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
-Holy mackerel!
-Thank you, man.
-Holy moley!
That's exactly right.
Standing ovation. That is how
you do it right there.
Nathan Macintosh.
That is how you do it.
-Appreciate you guys.
-"Money Never Wakes"
is available on YouTube.
We'll be right back.
That was phenomenal.